uh well as you can see the business
secretary quasi quartet joins us in the
studio great to see you this morning and
of course we will be dwelling on england
in just a moment
and of course uh the latest revelations
on covet but but
you're making a fairly significant
announcement i have to say today in
terms of life sciences tell us about it
absolutely right um life sciences have
been really at the forefront
of our fight uh against covid and people
know
around the world that the uk is really a
leader a world
leader in the life sciences and today
we're launching
the life sciences vision which is
essentially a strategic look
at how we can maximize uh great
potential
and our ability in this really crucial
area it's all about
being able to get proper medicine have
high level research
and critically commercializing that
research making great businesses
out of uh really strong fundamental
science
well like any any progress that can be
made particularly on cancer dementia
anything like that learning the
successes from covert 19 i think people
will look absolutely
but at the same time we are now in a
situation where
we were listening to the health
secretary yesterday we could be seeing
cases
new daily cases in excess of a hundred
thousand
over the summer i just want to dig down
just a little bit deeper into
into what that might actually mean if
we're talking about cases of a hundred
thousand a day
perhaps by the time we reach august by
by the 16th of august when
when the rules change on self-isolation
you could have over
a million and a half people
self-isolating because
they have had they had a positive test
you could have probably
double that people that they've come
into contact with even people who've
been double vaccinated
who would also be off work can we just
have someone from the government concede
there will be millions of people who
will be isolating this summer
as a result of the unlocking i don't
think you can necessarily conclude that
there'll be millions
we've always said significantly we've
always said that significant numbers the
numbers would be going up but of course
the critical thing neil is what
the hospitalization rates and uh the
fatalities as well and the numbers we've
seen on that
have been much much lower than anyone
anticipated
and that's because because of the
success of the vaccination program
and i think that's what's giving people
protection we've always said uh we've
always believed that um
infection rates might go up but the
critical point is what their
the effect of those uh infection rates
is and i think the vaccination
double doses particularly give a measure
of protection that we're
that we're happy with it will clearly
though however have an effect on
business which we'll talk about in just
a second
but in addition long covet is it is
clearly a thing
and if we're talking about a hundred
thousand new cases a day
i mean estimates vary but a ballpark
figure of five thousand people a day
acquiring long covered or or in at some
point in the future achieving
uh acquiring long covered symptoms i
mean that's that's not beyond the
imagination
is it it's not beyond the imagination
but i think we've got to get uh i think
you're getting ahead of
of where we are because uh
what i speak to what i like what i hear
is that we can't simply
uh lock down the society forever we have
to reopen if we don't reopen
fully on the 19th of july the
implications of that would be simply
just to delay all of this
uh till perhaps september and and in the
winter
where things would become more difficult
so it's a balancing act we have to
decide
uh what to do and i think this is the
best uh course of action i mean
viewers will see that i have my i've had
a vaccine badge on this morning my
second jack was yesterday which is
explains in part why i'm a little bit
grumpier this morning
than usual but why if we're going to
open up the country
in july why are people like me gonna
have to wait until
august to avoid self-isolating if i come
into contact like this
at this distance from someone who's
covered 19 positives yeah i mean again
there's always a balance so people on
the one hand are saying
that uh the 19th of july is too soon for
general reopening and other people are
saying
uh that it's not soon enough in the case
of cell phone isolation we feel that he
does
delaying it for four weeks does give a
measure of protection it allows more and
more people to be jabbed
and we think that that's uh that's a
precaution that that's
worth uh worth taking but we're opening
up hospitality people
will be in pubs bars restaurants
potentially without wearing their masks
we understand of course that the
hospitality sector 16 to 34 year olds
make up 60 percent of the workforce
and none of that well very few of them
will be double vaccinated
even by the middle of august do you
accept the fact that the hospitality
industry is going to be hit
incredibly hard if hundreds of thousands
even millions of people
are going to be self-isolated as a
result of us opening up perhaps
in the view of some just a little bit
too early i think we're making all sorts
of assumptions here well we've got
um uh we've got to make sampling as
we're modeling we're modeling yeah we've
got to make
but we're but you're always looking at
uh the worst possible case
my own view about the hospitality sector
is that they were very very keen to
reopen if you speak to pub owners if you
speak to people
in the hospitality business they were
very disappointed that we didn't open up
on the 21st of june
and i think many of them the majority
would say that this is the actual
the right precaution to be to be taking
that very happy i think they were all
very happy because they assumed that
come july the 19th people who were
double vaccinated would be able to avoid
self-isolating i mean obviously you're
the business sector you know a fair
amount about business but
you know julian metcalf you know the
founder of itsu the founder of press and
monge
i mean he's described this strategy and
i quote as completely and utterly mental
well you can't have it both ways on the
one hand we're saying that we want to
reopen but we're giving a measure of
precaution in terms of delaying
um the the self-lifting the
self-isolation restrictions it's a
balance
it's not it's not a perfect uh solution
but on the one hand we're saying
that we can reopen and on the other hand
we're saying that we want to give a
little bit more
protection in terms of the
self-isolation rules sure but it's not
even just people in business that are
saying this in the head of the
hospitality uk has made similar comments
to mr metcalf i mean ian duncan smith
makes the point look
why go into a pub where people are not
still adhering to the rule of sex
you know where there's no social
distancing because in all likelihood
if you go to the pub more than a couple
of times a week you will get pinged
at some point and you will have to
isolate so the big thing here
is that we need to rely on people's
judgment uh there's a
common sense and a degree of individual
responsibility
that's always going to be ultimately
what we have to rely on and in this
instance
we've said we're going to reopen people
will be allowed
not to wear masks to do what they they
choose
but also the businesses themselves will
be conducting uh business in a
responsible way
i think this is perfectly reasonable
just in terms of
of who might well be affected i mean we
understand of course
the younger you are the less likely it
is that you've had a vaccine certainly
to
be double vaccinated isn't it the case i
mean you
you don't accept the figure of several
million people isolating
others have suggested it it's fairly
standard
but that means the infection will be
running through
young people won't it once again the
youngest in our society those that have
lost frankly
from certain perspectives the most in
all of this will once again have to
have to suffer tell me that this isn't
you know heard immunity by another name
so again i always say there's a balance
when the
uh this awful illness struck uh it was
very apparent that uh certain groups
were much more vulnerable than others
in the case of covid it was older people
that's why
the vaccination rollout happened the way
it did we we targeted older more
vulnerable
people and the view the medical view was
that younger people
had more protection than more vulnerable
groups
uh clearly we are looking at vaccinating
younger people we're looking at what
jcvi are going to say
um but we feel that on balance
uh the best approach is to try and get
our kids back into school and get them
back
uh into normal life where do you
personally sit on the idea of
vaccinating you know
12 years and above well i don't know
what the medical uh opinion is i would
definitely defer to the jcvi on that and
they're going to
make their their ruling or their their
judgment uh public very soon
do you not though have any concerns no
one in government around the cabinet
table expressing concern you know you
think back to kind of
you know late last year cases were
nowhere near 100 000 a day
but infection was running rampant in
parts of the country in kent for example
and a variant of concern emerged i mean
if we're talking about
running higher than at the highest point
you're in the january peak
in terms of cases there is a real risk
isn't there
that we're just you know playing a
waiting game until another domestically
produced
perhaps even more resistant to vaccine
at variant emergencies
so again there's as i always say there's
a balance but the critical difference
between
this time and late last year has of
course been the vaccine rollout we've
had 75 million doses
we've had two thirds of the population
uh certainly getting the first dose
and that's a completely different
scenario than was the case last year
just to just sit with businesses and of
course plenty of people
been challenging the government on the
the removal of the mandatory requirement
the mandatory wearing of masks where do
you sit on that i mean what in what
circumstances will you be wearing a mask
so i've always said that
uh i believe in individual
responsibility i think businesses
uh have a uh their own discretion their
own judgment
i think uh individuals should also use
their own judgment
um personally i would i use the tube a
lot in london
uh and i would probably use them wear a
mask in that context in the tube
in public transport that's a personal
view it's not something that i would
mandate or necessarily dictate to other
people
but you'd be quite happy for businesses
say airlines
hospitality sector to require to
continue to require people wearing a
mask inside their premises yes i mean
actually before covid it was very
interesting that businesses always had
um have always had the ability to to
prescribe
um certain um health or they've always
had that
and i think we're going back to the to
that situation people have forgotten
that actually businesses did have some
discretion in terms of what people
um could come could wear or the thing
that people have always struggled with
this is that the wearing of mass yeah
there's a degree to which it's a
prophylactic measure that you're looking
after yourself but it is in essence
about looking after others
i mean if you are someone who say has
leukemia you're immunosuppressed you're
sitting on public transport
do you think that they have a right to
demand that other people wear masks
so if we wind the clock back to
pre-covid we had people who are
immunosuppressed we had flu
and what would happen in those days was
that the they would take the advice from
their doctors they'd take medical advice
and i think i'd expect that to continue
uh post
one quick question just before you go of
course the football on tonight's
we i i will be not necessarily
supporting with full voice but i'll
certainly be cheating a little bit from
the sidelines how do you think it's
gonna go
i think england will win um we haven't
conceded a goal yet i think it's pretty
remarkable you've got scotland
i don't want to jinx i don't want to
jinx anything um you know government
ministers predicting uh uh
football uh games probably isn't the
best thing for us to do but
i think i think on form if you look at
what's happened i think england have got
a really good chance and i hope
i hope they can uh they can actually
convert their
brilliant performances into a victory
tonight we will soon find out we'll may
air quite a question thank you
this morning thanks